Welcome back to Drew's News
and here to spread the holiday cheer,
we've got the youngest member of our Drew Crew.
It's the Shirley Temple King himself, Leo Kelly.
(audience cheering)
What is up?
How are you guys?
How are you?
Oh, great. We're so happy you're here.
I'm so happy I'm here.
How are you?
I'm good, honey.
Great.
How was your guys's Thanksgiving?
Mine was great.
And I had all of my daughter's family,
which is my family, and we just had a blast.
We spent three days together cooking and shopping
and just merriment.
Yeah, that's awesome.
Right?
As soon as Thanksgiving is over, my family,
we just go straight to Christmas.
Oh, totally.
I think, Ross, you like to do your Christmas tree, like,
on Thanksgiving.
Yeah, last bite of turkey and then I'm like,
"Let's go put up the tree."
I'm just like you.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
High five.
Leo, how was your Thanksgiving?
Mine was great.
We hung out at my grandma's, watch football, had Turkey,
you know, all the Thanksgiving classics.
All the classics, all the trimmings.
Yep.
All right, well, let's kick this off
with a toast with our friendly Christmas cocktail, Leo.
What have we go?
We have Santa's Hat Shirley Temple.
Now, you might be thinking,
is this just an ordinary Shirley Temple?
No, it's a Santa's Hat Shirley Temple.
Of course.
(audience laughs)
You start off with a normal Shirley Temple.
If you don't know what that is,
you've been living under a rock, just kidding.
(everyone laughs)
You mix together ginger ale, a splash of grenadine,
a bunch of ice, and, of course, three cherries.
So, here's a Christmas twist.
All you do is you take your glass
and you dip it in some sort of
like frosting.
Oh.
Or a marshmallow cream, in this case,
we're using marshmallow cream.
Oh, yum.
Let's just
get that rim all smothered in it.
Okay, gotta get it all gooey.
All right.
Oh, it's stuck.
(Ross and audience laugh)
It really did get stuck.
Yeah.
But it's gonna be a good adhesive.
It is.
That Santa's snow
is gonna stick right on.
Is this coconut?
That is, yes, coconut flakes.
Oh, so we're gonna roll it in the coconut
and then it sticks to the rim, right?
Mhmm.
And that's, like, the fluffy part of Santa's hat.
Oh, cute.
(audience applauds)
Oh.
And then we get to drink the real one.
Cheers you guys.
Look, you guys, and this
is what it looks like-
Cheers.
When it's all done.
I love this. Oh wait.
And then Leo, don't forget though,
we put the candy cane in,
and don't forget the maraschino cherries.
Of course not.
Right here.
(audience cheers)
Cute, I love it.
Cheers guys.
I love you, Leo.
I love you, Rossy.
That's good.
That is so good.
Great.
I got my daily spill
when I go on the Drew Barrymore Show, but whatever.
(Ross and audience laughs)
It happens, it happens.
It happens.
By the way, I'm going to adopt that.
Yep.
All right, well, while we sip on these,
you want to do a little story with us?
Of course, I'd love to.
Okay, great.
What do you think about this?
Do you know who Martha Stewart is?
Uh-huh. Yeah.
Who is she?
She's a chef and my favorite thing that she cooks
is cookies.
You know what, you're right.
You are so right.
Okay, well, "Martha Stewart Living" reports
on a new study that says if you decorate your house
for the holidays, you might seem friendlier
to your neighbors.
They say the lights, the deer, the snowmen,
they all make it look like a friendly family lives inside.
What do you think about this?
I actually believe that theory because, one moment,
I actually believe that theory
because whenever I'm on the bus on my way to school
or back from school or I'm in my parents' car,
I always see them going around, like,
straight after Thanksgiving through November 1st,
I see them popping up everywhere,
and our town really goes out on Christmas decorations.
And when I look at them, I think, wow,
that person really took the time
to decorate their house-
Aww.
To make other people happy.
Yeah.
That's what I think.
And then, if I'm in a bad mood or I'm in a good mood,
that just makes my day even better.
What do you think?
I agree.
(audience applauds)
That's the whole point, right?
Yeah.
It is.
It's like a big welcome mat.
Yeah.
It's either saying I just want to visually present you
with joy or come on in.
Yeah.
And most of the time, it's come on in.
(audience laughs)
Well, we should test that theory, Leo.
Let's just go knock on a bunch of doors
and see what happens.
(Ross and audience laugh)
Okay. I'll do that.
Okay.
Well, we'll do it together.
All right, listen.
Everyone's favorite Christmas villain, can we think of it?
Guess.
Grinch.
Grinch, yeah.
It's Grinch.
It's the Grinch.
"Architectural Digest" actually reports
that now, you can take a vacation in the Grinch's lair.
It's a rental in Boulder, Utah
carefully designed to look just like his cave
and the signs outside say, "Leave now," and "Get lost,"
kind of the opposite of the welcome and come on in.
And inside, you'll find his furry green shoes
and the fantastical organ.
What do you think, Leo?
Would you come on in or go away?
Well, on one condition, I'd come in,
and I think you all might agree with me.
As long as the Grinch is somewhere else,
doesn't matter
if it's the North Pole
(audience laughs)
or somewhere else, he just needs to be out of there.
If he is in a grumpy spirit,
he needs to be out of there
because I do not want him going around ruining my Christmas,
judging me what to do.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Preach.
I was paddle boarding, kayaking with my daughter.
We went to San Diego and the guy literally goes,
I was like, "That's such a cool house,"
and he goes, "Oh, that's Theodor Geisel's house."
I was like, "Dr. Seuss?"
He goes, "Yeah, and his wife owned a house up on the hill
because every holiday, she would get so upset
about the holidays that she would just go
to the house on the hill and avoid everyone,
and that was the inspiration for the Grinch."
Really?
Oh.
Yes, put that in your-
I never knew,
I would've never known.
I never knew that either.
Put that in your "Architectural Digest" article.
Well, Leo, as always,
we've been on this show together since the very beginning,
and as long as we are here, I'd really like to be together,
would that be okay?
Yes.
Thank you, Leo.
Cheers.
Aww.
(audience applauds)
Everybody, Leo Kelly,
and if you'd like the recipe
to Santa's Hat Shirley Temple,
it's on our website.
(upbeat music)